[Music]
hello everyone Perry here in Toronto for
TIFF 2019 and I'm so excited right now
because we are about to talk to some of
the cast of the Goldfinch we have Oakes
Begley and Sarah Paulson here I'm so
happy you guys had time to swing by you
are something else in this movie and you
already know how highly I think of you
so I feel like I had a separate that
it's okay you can give Oakes all of the
you know celebration he deserves so
Oakes I wanted to start out by asking
you about the audition process was
reading the notes I know there was an
extensive search for this role so was
this the kind of situation where you
just have to go in so many times when
you're waiting for the word to come in I
think I was I was actually flying back I
don't remember from where or to where
but I got a call that it was like
something that I was going to go up for
and my mom had read the book previous
and she was like oh my god she was so
incredibly excited and so straight off
the bat like I had already had someone
in my family that was really interested
in it and then you're talking to her I
got really excited for the audition and
then I think the first one may have been
a tape and then so I taped an audition I
sent it in that went probably pretty
smoothly
I think it was and then I went in to you
yeah and then I went into the casting
office and that's when I met John and I
think I actually did a chemistry test
with Finn at that point so when you read
the scenes together that we had together
and then I did some stuff earlier with
John just the scenes that we're without
Finn and then that was pretty much it I
think after that I had got the roles so
it wasn't crazy for me but I'm sure it
was very difficult for them to like I
don't know look for someone I mean I do
you have to have the right feel I think
especially at the beginning of the story
it's the hardest one here's the heart of
the movie and it's where you carry you
know the soul of the things throughout
the whole piece since it spends much
time so well it was worth all the hard
work they put into it to find here you
really are something else in it and
Sarah I know you're a big fan of the
book and I'm just fascinated by the
adaptation process and I always wonder
like what is the better way to go about
it in some cases do you read the book
first and then watch the movie so as a
big fan yourself and someone who has now
worked on this adaptation what do you
make of reading the Goldfinch versus
watching it which way I haven't watched
it because I don't like to watch myself
so I haven't seen it but but I loved
this book so profoundly but I think
anytime you have a piece of literature
that you can use as a blueprint because
obviously as Oakes was saying earlier
that like you know you can't take an
almost 800 page novel and compress it
and have every rich tiny detail stay
which is what I think I give such credit
to john crowley for because he brought
so much of and insisted that so much of
the book yesterday and and all exactly
the right things that make it so
indelible the book that then I think is
I'm sure is successful in the movie but
I think it's always as much information
as you can get and to have you know what
the what the author intended because
there's so many little details that are
the way that Theo is described or the
way that Xander's described or Larry is
described a mrs. Barbara's described you
can really really really gather so much
of what the author intended and then
allow your interpretation to come
through but I found it really helpful to
have this Bible as it were you know and
and she is an incredibly descriptive oh
that's very good stuff in there yeah
using the book as a tool you can
absolutely pull everything from the book
and and put together the scenes which is
awesome and that's I think one of the
things that makes this movie so very
similar to the novel which is awesome
and I think it'll really satisfy the
fans of the novel yeah one other
question I wanted to ask you about
joining the project is that you lobbied
for the role of zan drives which struck
me I wanted the part very badly
I had actually when I read the book I
was sitting alone in my bed we don't
talk about that part about it but I was
we could not put the book down and I
said out loud if they ever make a movie
of this book I I want to play Sandra I
want to play Sandra and so when I heard
they were making the movie I lobbied
very hard and and you know to John's
credit and also I mean I do understand
there was a resistance to my doing it I
think he knew me from the People vs OJ
Simpson and I don't I can understand why
you don't kind of go that girl that
played Marcia Clark she can play Sandra
but the beauty of and the great gift and
opportunity from an acting standpoint is
to try to immerse yourself in something
that and and so I loved the challenge of
putting on a wig getting a spray tan
making a tape with a casting director
John was not there and bringing my own
cigarettes into the audition screaming
in my car to try to get a gravel in my
voice that that that I don't actually
have that Sandra has a bit of a deeper
voice and you know that and I even
thought like if I don't get this job at
least I gave it a real a real real
effort and and then when John wanted to
talk to me on the phone and I heard all
the names of the girls that that they
were talking to and I was like oh I'm
never gonna get this movie ever ever
gonna get this movie so it was a big it
was a big exciting day for me when I got
the call I I couldn't believe it I can't
understand ya idea it's just like I look
at the unsung belen this movie and it's
there's really kind of nothing like it
well a building can't stand up if you
don't have all the support be yes so
it's like you really you have to have
the heart and soul of a thing and you do
need the the flying buttresses I just
said that but you know that you need the
things that that help keep everything
the movie wouldn't be the same without
all of the incredible ensemble members
like it's it's awesome to see all the
pieces come together and when watching
the film you'll really see that I mean
it's it's great and and everybody had a
real passion on on the film and you can
really see it it's really awesome that
actually makes me think of it another
question that came up in a different
interview recently I was talking to
Kelvin Harrison jr. who is actually here
with waves this year and he watches a
lot of interviews with
actors to just learn things for himself
and one of the things when I asked him
you know what would you ask someone that
you admire he wanted to know what your
opinion is on like especially for you
Oaks in this situation with a great
ensemble a whole bunch of very talented
people around you what is it like both
being part of an ensemble but also
needing to like be a leader amongst that
group how do you find the balance with
something like that that is an
incredibly I know
humbling statement there I mean to be
saying that I'm a leader of that
incredible ensemble is unbelievable but
I guess it's just about working with
John and I feel like John and I had a
real chemistry and we really just
powered through so many awesome scenes
and unjust John would really like direct
me in certain ways that I couldn't even
understand while I was working and then
afterwards I'd be like that cake was
incredible like how did that even happen
but John is just that kind of director
where he just plays with everything and
just makes everything come together and
so that's a great tool that helps as
well and I mean Ansel and I both carry
the the role so I guess that's also
helpful as well I mean Ansel and I both
kind of split that 50/50 which is makes
it a bit easier to carry the burden I
guess you could say all right to follow
ups to the ensemble question one of
everybody in this cast who are you the
most intimidated to meet this
ya know yeah probably Nicole Nicole
Kidman just because like no way and
exactly knowing that you're gonna go
work with me like what I felt that way
talking for like driving to set the day
that I was like gonna meet her and
actually work with her I was just like
butterfly I'm like I don't know it's
crazy but then as soon as I met her she
was like the most conversational awesome
person it was great and and she's just
she's an awesome awesome person and who
of the ensemble surprised you the most
who when you got on set with them they
brought something out of you that you
didn't even realize you could do Luke
Luke Wilson the scenes with with me and
Luke looking back and I know you don't
like looking at yourself or seeing you
but I when I first saw the film after
after filming it which I guess it was
probably a couple months ago now the
scenes with the two of us
he really had so much character that I
could work off of and react to you and
that really I think just just completely
pulled those scenes together and I I
think he was probably the most fun
person to work off of those scenes with
Luke you and Finn were like the most fun
ever because it was just a lot of really
divert like really really different
personalities and everybody had a
different kind of want and a need and so
I think it created a lot of like yeah it
was awesome one other thing I wanted to
ask without spoiling necessarily the
content of the scene but one of the most
striking scenes in the movie to me is a
scene where you two are having a very
urine emotional place you're kind of
high and there's just so much happening
around you too and then you've got Roger
Deakins behind the lens and all of this
is happening so what is it like
preparing for something like that does
it feel as chaotic to you on set as
frenetic as it feels when I'm watching
it on the screen John keeps a really
calm peaceful set - and so as
knowing that I had to do something
emotional and then he had to be in a
place in an alternate reality and Roger
is so quiet and you know I was almost
afraid to talk to him ever because I was
like the most starstruck I've ever been
around Roger Deakins and was just you
know like good morning mr. Deakins and
hello you know so it was but he was he's
so quiet you know and he doesn't he's
just very quiet he takes his work very
seriously and he observes and I think
the the crew part of part of the thing
of working with Roger is that everybody
is very quiet so that he can do what
he's doing and it kind of created a tone
of real usually on sets it's very
chaotic in between setups and this was
very quiet set in between setups and I
think it was a wonderful place to work
from because you weren't dealing with
just the chaos in your head and the
chaos outside of that you were just
dealing with what was in your
imagination now I wanted to ask you
something but I have a feeling you're
probably gonna get asked a lot today so
I'm first so I win okay one of the
things that I love most about this story
is that the Goldfinch the painting isn't
just a famous painting it's something
with real history and meaning and it
fills a void in his life so what is the
Goldfinch in your life do you have any
you know personal thing you know that
thing you would grab in a fire something
like that that means the world to you I
mean it's not like an object but my dog
my dead dog but still I hate to be a big
downer but glad that we have the same
the same yeah he's a shih tzu poodle you
can't say [ __ ] Sue on television you
could say a lot more than that on this
channel puto shih tzu poodle and he he's
awesome he doesn't actually look that
much like a shih tzu poodle but he yeah
he's got so much character
his name's mochi and I don't know he's
just the one thing that I go to when I'm
sad or when I'm feeling lost or down or
anything like that like I could just sit
there mo yeah you sure can
yeah I can't do that anymore Oaks cuz my
dogs dead who fight
Oh God you need to fill that void in
your life get yourself a puppy well life
is life you know having a baby I know we
should go talk shopping except we can't
shop it we got a rescue it that's even
better
that's better we can just go in the time
when the time comes you come over to
Collider we have a puppy video series
going with adoptable puppies you come in
and we'll make sure you get the perfect
puzzles all right before I have to let
you guys go
we're gonna play a new Collider game and
it's simply colliders most memorable so
I have seven topics here I'm gonna list
them to you and you just tell me what
your most memorable moment in that
category is starting with Festival
premiere festival premiere like first
time ever most memorable festivals to me
are near I was in London that's a good
one good one good answer good answer
like struck and it was I was an awesome
tour and it was the first time I've been
to Europe in a very long time so that
was awesome but I have to say that and I
was wearing this really cool furry suit
right to the fat shake it was really
cool experience and going to London was
was great I would say that's probably
the most memorable mine would probably
be the 12 years of slave premiere and if
I would probably be the one it was it
was very thrilling to sort of be not
only a part of that movie but to sort of
stand near the moment when Lupita became
the pizza and you know the world got to
first you know see her brilliant
performance and and meet this sort of
fashion chameleon and this great artist
and I was there when it happened man so
that's pretty memorable that makes me
happy
a most memorable meal ever didn't lie
ever what are you nuts my gonna be like
a Dairy Queen blizzard it's the best
boss balancer you can play yeah to me
anytime I'm gonna dipped very cream cone
or a blizzard or a jack-in-the-box shake
or anything involving ice cream yeah I
don't know young Java most memorable
for God's sake you gotta train him well
and you're starting off great right now
I don't have like a favorite he went to
London to the festival did you have a
meal there where you were like wait wait
we can fix this right now both of you
because you like ice cream and you need
a memorable meal go on over to sweet
Jesus before you leave here Jesus it's
called it's called hygiene just right by
the light box and it is incredible okay
will I be able to fit into my dress
after I probably nod I'm like I'm still
fitting into my clothes and I've been
eatin sweet Jesus every year every year
come here sweet most memorable scene
you've ever shot oh man I wish I had
these questions in advance I feel I feel
put on the spot here um you can say the
one with me you're allowed to say that
yeah my yeah and I can say the one with
you um we don't that's the scene in the
Goldfinch where oh that's a good one
where the unmentionable thing that we
can't talk about when I get very upset
with him and he's you know stoned or
whatever you're doing tripping tripping
and I've got some information I've got
to give him that was a pretty great day
I don't know there's a you know I feel I
feel them lucky I've I've you know
living that American Horror Story life
that I've lived for so long I've gotten
to do a lot of wild wild wild things so
it'd be hard to how about just American
Horror Story . that's a very that's er
might be the fairest answers the second
you said American Horror Story I
challenged myself to think of my
favourite scene and I don't think I
could pick just one and sometimes yeah I
don't know sometimes it was a
particularly you know all the stuff I
did with Jessica Lange was totally
thrilling and understandable yeah so
it's hard to pick just one it's like a
Lay's potato chip yeah I'm doing a lot
of product placement right now I wanna
get a gift card from Dairy Queen
jack-in-the-box
thank you I'm about to gain 20 pounds
for a job let's bring it I would say
probably some of the scenes when I was
filming Pete's dragon was the first
experience I ever had working with green
screen which is always very interesting
yeah I don't know some of them just
working off of nothing because it's just
a green tennis ball or whatever you're
actually looking at so I would say some
of those are some really memorable times
in the forests of New Zealand yeah
pretty that was like most man and I
wasn't even there just when you're
talking about it so pretty powerful
wrapping it up okay what is your most
memorable wrap gift um most memorable
wrap gift ever
I got go ahead - I had one big print of
the Goldfinch mm given to me from I
believe Warner Brothers and then I got
eight I didn't get that from Warner
Brothers I feel like like a life-sized
smaller on wood board replica of the
Goldfinch which was really cool I have
that sitting in my room and that's
probably the coolest gift
mine would probably be the slate from
the Epis from the episode of American
Horror Story that I directed that I
didn't know they were gonna give me in
the you know that was pretty cool
so good man thank you thank you guys so
much thank you your time today again
huge congratulations on the movie to
everybody out there the Goldfinch hits
theaters on September 13th we are here
at TIFF and the reason we are doing this
interview right now is because of our
good friends at Nordstrom Canada so huge
thank you to them another thank you to
both of you we'll be back with more TIFF
coverage soon